this talk is titled the trouble with
three values
irreproducible 'ti and science this is a
talk I'm gonna I'm gonna show the
outline of the talk first
first I'm gonna motivate it took a bit
I'll provide a bit of an introduction
I'll talk about why p-values are uniform
and why that's important and confusing
sometimes I will explain the concepts of
statistical power that's related to how
one interprets p-values I will talk
about publication bias and how it
affects reproducibility in science and
then I'll give an example with location
tests so historically like in 700 slap
laughs wanted to use data to make
decision so he looked up half a million
births and you want to ask is it
statistically significant that there's
more boys being born than then goes and
he came to the answer he came to was yes
but notice that he had a lot of data to
work with and that's important there's
gonna be important it took unfortunately
p-values have acquired by reputation
they can be confusing and misleading and
this reputation is not entirely
warranted data analysis itself assay is
a complicated thing and p-values it's
just one way of looking at the data if
one uses them correctly they're very
powerful to this talk was motivated by
an internal email question that that was
asked by one of us who was confused as
to how it with good cause because it can
be confusing if you they can be hard to
get your head around so I'm gonna try
and provide this talk it's gonna be like
an intuition builder I'm gonna try and
not took them give a lot of definitions
just try and give intuition of how
p-values work and then I'm gonna give an
example of why misuse of p-values
learn to reproducibility crisis in
science with like horror horrific
numbers really like in and very recent
meta studies in 2015 could only
reproduce like 36 percent of results for
instance so this is something like I
find very interesting and horrific and
it's very it's a hot topic now a paper
from last year is this is like some
discussion that's happening right now
about science and statistics so the two
main frameworks for data analysis the
basin and the frequentist framework and
I'm not gonna like get into the rabbit
hole of defending one or the other or
giving or explain them a little because
this is obviously a huge topic I'm just
gonna provide like the intuition that
the Bayesian asks the question what's
the probability of a model that we want
to use given some data and the
frequentist framework as the opposite
less natural question which is what's
the probability of the data given our
model basis conceptually easier but
often harder in practice you have to be
very specific with your assumptions that
could be very hard to compete
numerically so that's one of the reasons
that the cuentas model even though it's
less popular today it still it still
very useful you can you can get a number
with very easily with a with a different
this model and then you just have to be
clever as to how to interpret or
cautious cautious don't rush to
conclusions I'm gonna I'm gonna give a
little advance of the of the final
remarks that I'm gonna be here just so
that you bear in that we bear in mind
whether took is that this no magic
recipe and data analysis there's no way
to plug in a thing in a black box and
and get a number that that is robust you
have to give good data good assumptions
and you have to understand your problem
to get robust called new quantitative
conclusions so
we want to draw inferences from our data
and a simple question is does the data
support a hypothesis and the first
effort to do that is we summarize the
data with a number so we have vector
observations and we want to first get a
simple number that we call statistic
hence the word statistics an example is
that we take the variance of the data
and we just multiply it by n minus 1
which is there n is no mother dead and
there the amount the length of the data
set and the second step is that we use
the statistic to try and determine
whether the data supports our hypothesis
so I'm gonna now give a definition and
we're gonna illustrate this definition
because the definition is a bit
confusing itself so so the p-value is
the probability that the sample
statistic is smaller than the observed
statistic assuming or conditions is what
this little thing says this little
sideways hat says or now model h0 which
is called the null hypothesis and this
is expressed in in Mathematica will be
expressed like this and to compute this
probability we must we have to know the
distribution of statistic for example if
our data is normally distributed which
is often a good approximation by the way
to follow-up data the statistic T that
we we had here will be we have a
chi-squared distribution and we're gonna
shown a little example of how these
things are derived so for instance we
have beta x that's normally distributed
with mean mean mu and variance Sigma and
if we apply this transformation we we
subtract the mean and we divide by the
standard deviation this is now
distributed normal distribution with
mean 0 and variance standard deviation 1
if we square this data we get a
chi-squared distribution with parameter
1 and if we sum this data where you get
Y squared distribution and now we have a
number now we have statistic a
chi-square distribution with parameter n
because we had N equals 10 here Wolfram
language provides many built-in tests
that automatically computer statistic
and know about underlying distribution
to compute the p-value so this is this
is why framework does for you and a
modified version of the test statistic
here T it's what's using the piston
quite chi-square test for instance so
when an example of how to use this you
we have some data and then we just ask
we we asked a distribution fit test to
up to does this does this can this be
explained as a Maxwell distribution of
some prior with some parameter and the
answer is is yes or rather the answer is
we don't reject the hypothesis if I that
you can never give positive answers like
we this is a in the this is you can only
falsify the in or Bertha see because you
can never say it's definitely true so
are an important things that p-value is
a uniformly distributed and intuitively
I want to give an intuition why that's
the case
this this probability calculation this
p-value gives the position of X amongst
a salted sample drawn from the null
hypothesis h0
normalized by a total number of samples
and if X is drawn itself from the same
distribution that's a typo that should
be H 0 it will be distributed uniformly
intuitively if you just have a number of
samples and they all have the same
distribution if you swap them around
they'd be order the position in that in
a sorted sample is uniformly distributed
you're equally likely to draw the 10th
element in a sort example than the last
element so that's why p-values are
uniformly distributed and the I mean we
can see they say like if we subscibe we
we sample from our parade Pareto
distribution printer
and then wind subsample we just choose
random elements from that sample I have
a compute the the CDF which is an
efficient way of computing this
probability then it will be uniformly
distributed so now we the the the next
step is that we reject their we reject
the null hypothesis if this p-value is
smaller than a than a threshold that we
call significance level and this
significance level has traditionally
been say at 5% and this is something
that's now being questioned I'll talk
about this later
and crucially this means that we have a
false rejection rate of alpha of 5% in
this case because of choosing the
significance level even if our data
comes from a distribution we will always
throw away mistakenly throw away 5% so
for example if we have a collection of
samples we can we can we can again
proved that this using distribution fit
test that this thing is uniformly
distributed and for that reason we're
going to throw away significance level
number of them so more on this P I said
this before p-values can only falsify
hypothesis not confirm them so the
p-value is very small it is unlikely
that our hypothesis true i ET the data
comes from the model to lower the false
rejection rate that we have like this
mistakenly thrown away of good samples
we we can lower the significance level
so for instance by default we
fortunately reject 5% if we ask for the
short test conclusion on a sample that
with that we that will create it here
and and we count how many of them are
are we're rejecting is it's 5% if we
lower the significance level to 0.5% for
instance we project point five percent
falsely
so with this understanding of how this
is a like inescapable facts of using P
values we can appreciate this ask a
silly joke that it's very that it's very
representative of how P values of our
people understand P values and meet the
media and it's times P value so this is
these some guys being asked to do some
tests and they go away and they do 20
tests with a p-value that's 1 over 20
whether a significance level that's 1
over 20 and one of them is significant
and they say and and the news will be
that green jelly beans are linked to
acne with 95 percent confidence this is
bollocks like this language is very
misleading only 5% chance of incidence
no that's not true this is not asking a
question it's the the the useful what's
useful if this p-value is very very very
small then you can you have some
confidence that this is true otherwise
you should be very careful with these
conclusions so thinking out the let's
talk let's look at this let's look at
this scary fact again this again this is
a very recent meta-analysis they took a
hundred papers published recently in
psychology and these are like Nobel
prizes in science the decisions are made
these mistakes so like this is a mistake
that is really and has caused a crisis
of faith in science with good reason in
my in my opinion because this is not
just psychology which is I mean nobody
cares about oh but in medicine this
happens as well in pharmaceutical tests
this happen as well so very very serious
stuff and you know 70% of them are wrong
and this is partly there are many
contributing factors P Hawking like we
we see what we want to see like this
this is very data analysis very
complicated but but publication biases
is a particular culprit that's kind of
easy to to eliminate and it's one of the
main contribution go
to be dim factor so let's let's look at
statistical power and how it works
so we've seen that by law in
significance level we can know where the
false rejection rate but if we want to
lower the force acceptance rate so
they're false negatives this is a bit
trickier so suppose we have some data
distributed at sites one an alternative
hypothesis and we want to test where
it's distributed as h naught which is
our null hypothesis and we're gonna be
sanitation here a bit to also use these
symbols to represent the distribution of
the statistic so we have a we have a
data we aggregated Twista to a number
and we're going to say that this is the
distribution of this number so and we're
also going to assume a two-sided test so
we're going to reject know if not only
if the p-value is very small but also
very close to one so here we have h1
which is a normal distribution the H nor
is 1 0 here sorry 0 1 and H 1 is 1 1 so
we have basically we can see here that
we have two hypotheses that have a lot
of overlap so the the no and the
alternative hypothesis is very similar
so it's gonna be very difficult to tell
one from the other two to disentangle
data that doesn't come from the null
hypothesis that from data that does and
this is the con this is what the concept
of statistical power encodes beta is the
probability that we falsely accept the
null hypothesis so beta here is the q1
and q2 are the the places at which we
would cut off which at which we would
reject the null hypothesis here and if
we integrate the orange curve from q1 to
q2 this is gonna give us the probability
that we falsely accept the null
hypothesis which is point 82% here and
the power is defined as 1 minus beta so
low power means our
both I know under alternative hypothesis
are very similar and it's hard to tell
them apart and one and it's in this
scenario it's very hard to do to make
any decisions to make robust conclusions
so and it also obviously depends on the
test statistic they use but also in the
data again like if we have data that's
like almost normally distributed
distributed but almost has the same mean
then you're not gonna be able to tell
them apart so here just like I just want
to see that like you can do this
computation with the distribution below
if you sample from this distribution and
do this counting that we did before this
probability using an empirical
distribution you're gonna get a very
similar result for power is 17% 69.9%
so publication bias isn't a very
important contributor to this
irreducibility crisis what happens the
publication of negative results are
suppressed i people only want to see
journals only want to see the things
like things like new things actually
happening and this results in most the
published ones being wrong and there's
two necessary conditions for this one is
that this sort result is very rare so
most results will be negative what you
try new things and it's hard to find
anything so most of the test the science
that you do is negative you don't find
you don't find anything and then if we
only publish those net positive results
then most of them are gonna be wrong and
this is let's let's see an example I
want to do these illustrations because
they're very once you cease process
they're easy to understand we have a the
result that we this sort result is rare
so 10% and this is like this is a 10% is
actually a huge number for DNA studies
for instance like you're trying lo2
combination of different base pairs and
see if they're related to some phenotype
or something and you're like it's gonna
be much lower than 1% of something but
like let's assume it's 10% for for the
case for the sake of the argument
and here we see that like if we most of
the most of our test statistics are
gonna be are gonna be negative are gonna
be there's nothing going on eight series
the null hypothesis and some of them are
gonna be something's going on and we I'm
using the same h1 as before so the the
the power is low there's a lot of
overlap between these two curves so if
we reject the null hypothesis which is
then what we usually what like the usual
case in these studies like we want to
we're looking for something so the null
hypothesis is we find nothing and we
only keep rejections I positive results
though the ones that journals want to
see we're gonna see that only 6% are
positive in this case so all the
rejections are the 6% and remember if it
was if we only had it so it'd be 5%
because that's their significance level
therefore and only 27% of these are
correct number slightly lower than this
psychology study by the same ballpark
just randomly choosing 10% and here we
see the histogram of what's actually
going on we had this we had this
histogram and then we we've literally
rejected everything in the middle that
had a p-value smaller than these two
thresholds and what we're left with is
this and the blue stuff is the stuff
that's correct and the orange stuff is
the stuff that is wrong and because
there was a much more orange stuff most
of us that most of the rich results are
wrong the power 17% probably that we
reject given h1 is 27% we can do the
same sort of analysis directly using
some base theorem so this is like very
basic and this is like a toy bassy an
example analysis with with cancer rate
this is like the first example you you
see when you when you learn base in base
and stuff and you you just apply Bayes
theorem this is based in what's if one
what's the probability of a correct
result assuming that
we've rejected is given by the
probability that we rejected given that
we had a sample form H 1 times the
probability of H 1 which is very low
time divided by the probability that we
reject and we compute this this is just
to remind us where Q 1 and Q 2 where and
we can compute this these numbers by
first looking at the two rejections
which are the probability that we reject
given now we're in h1 I significant
results and then just to compare we have
the force objections which we expect to
be alpha the significance level and this
is true this is like a sanity check we
can also compute the all the rejections
which is again probably will check given
that way in this mixture distribution
that we that we've defined here so most
of it is H naught and some of this
distribution is h1 effect frequency was
if we remember was like 10% and if we do
this number again we get 27% and base in
terms this is because of this prior
distribution for each one is solo I it's
hard to find a result so the posterior
is gonna is gonna be hard to make it
upstair bhai we can only update our
information so much so if you want to
improve power we can let's let's assume
we improve power and this is not not
always easy because we we we can find
the case where you know it can be hard a
túcume can be very stubborn or
adversarial but if we manage to improve
power so we have an another distribution
h2 which is has a lot less overlap this
time and we see that the power this time
is very high almost 1 if we look the
distribution of sample statistics we
again see that like this time the
there's a lot more orange but the green
stuff it doesn't overlap let's have the
blue here the blue stuff of comparison
and
again we play same trick only key
positive results this time we have 14%
because we have much more stuff in the
rejection area the green stuff
previously we're 60% and 70% of them are
correct so we've improved power and this
was a very easy and and we again same
plot we can see why this is true
we the orange stuff that we were
fortunately rejecting is here but we
have all this green stuff here that is
correct results but note that because
the prior was low to begin with still
even with like almost ninety-nine point
eight percent power we can't do better
than 70 percent so this is an important
thing and this is why it's crucial to
publish negative results and another
another I mean a complimentary thing to
do is is to raise the significance level
is lower the significance level so let's
take here point oh one percent and in
this case again same analysis we get a
similar picture that six this M 67% of
those also correct but the cost of
failing to reject some of these samples
from the alternative hypothesis and we
look at this picture again and we see
what's going on we just gone further or
further away to the tails and we see
that that where the in this regime we
managed to select more of the blue more
of the correct alternative hypothesis so
I'm almost out of time let's just
quickly look at an example of we're
trying to test two datasets the hub is a
mean and this is a typical case in
pharmaceutical tests we have a control
group and a drug and a drug group growth
drug group and we simulate this with a
Cauchy distribution which is heavy
tailed and and hence it's going to have
low power because it's gonna be a long
mixture of the two distributions and we
just use location test and with a
hypothesis test data or
the hypothesis that objective inquiry
and use this to figure to apply all the
tests that we have and and see the
shortest conclusion and we see that we
do not manage to reject in most of the
cases both with location test and with
distribution fit test but if we get a
bigger sample we will increase the power
and we will be able to confidently
reject the tests so I'm very I'm out of
time I'm just gonna conclude closing
remarks these are quotes the plural of
anecdote is no data small datasets don't
have a lot of information they're
inferences one can draw limited data
analysis simply a dialogue with the data
this is it's hard we you requires it
requires being very informed and even
when you are you make mistakes so one
has to be very careful not to dilute
oneself into thinking the one is making
informed decisions as a result of being
quantitative just because you have
numbered doesn't mean that like you
should believe you're number like you
have to be conservative and cautious
with with your with your analysis and
the recommendation is a criminal
commendation 2017 paper in nature that
we should at least use point five
percent so an order of magnitude lower
and that would help ameliorate some of
these courses but like there's still
data and I still high but this is this
is a the current recommendation thank
you very much sorry
you